I take you now to the year 1991.
Nina, you're a bouncing baby girl.
Yeah, I'm one.
Brian, you have just received
your first copy of AARP magazine.
Brian, no longer has to
pay to ride the public bus.
Today, we're going to talk about the Marvel teams
we want to see in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
There are a lot of teams to choose from in Marvel
comics. And we wrote about a lot of them over on
looper.com in our Marvel Teams We Want To See
In The MCU article. I'm going to mention some
of the ones that I know of that I definitely
would love to see in the MCU. And the first one
here is the Young Avengers, which we all know they
seem to be building. Can we all agree that the
Young Avengers are basically one phase away from
being announced? They're just going to wait for-
It's definitely going to
happen. There is no question.
Yeah. They're going to wait for Willy
and Billy to get a little older. Yes,
I know it's Tommy and Billy, but
I like Willy and Billy better.
Fantastic.
I think that's what they should've
been named, Willy and Billy.
You should tell Wanda that
for sure. She'll take it well.
It's the same name, just with one as a
nickname and then one as a different name.
Just saying, I don't think she handles criticism
particularly well, so I'd tread carefully.
Oh yeah, that's a good point. Nevermind. The Young
Avengers came out in, I'd say like the mid 2000s,
sort of as Marvel's riff on Teen Titans in
this interesting way. For the longest time,
the X-Men and the Teen Titans were kind of
corollaries between Marvel and DC, where
there was a lot of soap opera aspects, a
lot of younger characters interacting with
some older characters being placed in tough
situations. The X-Men started out as a school.
So a lot of the characters kind of have that
kind of feed in from the young superhero game
to the older superhero game. So X-Men
and Teen Titans were how they kind of
lined up. But then Marvel went and created
this book called The Young Avengers that had
pretty much altogether brand new versions, younger
versions of established Avengers characters.
It was really cool. So you have Kate Bishop,
who's going to be in the new Hawkeye show.
You had Speed and Wiccan, who are the
aforementioned Willy and Billy. Hulkling,
who's a skrull. We talked about this very recently
in a different video. And Patriot, I think was his
name who is Elijah Bradley's grandson. And Iron
Lad, who is a young version of Kang from the
future to our present, trying to change his own
villainous future. So there was a lot of really
cool stuff that they did that was a fun kind of
Marvel filtered version of Teen Titans that was
interesting. And I think that it went on for much
longer than I continued to read. So I would be
curious to see that show up. That was one of
them. Another one was The Future Foundation,
which is kind of a riff on The Fantastic Four
getting weirder and bigger with lots of strange
characters. I know Tom, you have some thoughts
about The Future Foundation. Do you want to-
I love The Future Foundation.
I think they're fantastic.
Pun intended.
They were terrific. Yeah, wocka. No, they were
great. Yeah, it was what? Late 2000s, early 2010s?
Mm-hmm.
They decided to expand the Fantastic Four
universe a little bit. They had this whole
skyscraper. And so, why not use it to
start educating and creating a better
tomorrow? That was the idea. It was nice. It was
optimistic sci-fi and it's a bunch of weirdos-
Oh, that's rare.
... and a bunch of other weirdos to
try and turn them into better weirdos.
Again, sort of like a riff on the X-Men, Teen
Titans thing where it's a lot of superpower
characters, but now they're in this school of
The Future Foundation and they're learning to be
better super weirdos. This is exactly
what you said. There The Fantastic Four,
Spider-Man was in there for a little while. You
got Sue and Reed Richards, two super-powered kids.
Valeria Richards in particular being super
duper smart. And then you had, what was it?
frank-
Like a clone of the Thinker?
Yeah.
Wasn't there a clone of the Thinker?
The Wizard.
The clone of the Wizard.
That was it, sorry. The Wizard isn't a wizard.
And the Dragon Man.
He's just a science bad guy. He was-
He's basically the leader with
a smaller head. Yeah, no. Yeah.
And the leader is just the Hulk,
but brains instead of muscles. See,
we're breaking down all the various ways in which
Marvel takes a concept and says, "What if
Hulk, but brains except muscles?" You know?
Right.
What if Hulk but brains expect muscles?
And how can we take one idea and make
five different permutations out of it?
Right, exactly.
Or 20 or 40 or 80.
Like they say, what if Spider-Man, butbad and gooey, and you get Venom. And
then you say, what if Venom but red,
and then you get Carnage. And then-
And gooier, yeah.
Gooier. Even gooier.
This time with more goo.
More goo. Double the goo.
Less goo, Toxin.
Yeah, no, that's exactly right.
Electric boog-a-goo. Is that anything?
It's something.
Not yet but it'll get there.
Okay. Yeah, we can workshop it.
So yeah, Future Foundation's a really fun
one. And so, obviously we'd have to wait
until Fantastic Four are introduced for anything
resembling the Future Foundation to happen, but
what a cool modern take on the Fantastic Four
story. Because back in the 60s, the Fantastic Four
is, hey, these four people stole a rocket ship,
went into space and turned super. And now it's
more like these four superheroes who do crazy
adventures are now kind of trying to make it so
that all these other strange beings in the world
are being geared towards a more positive future.
Putting some great responsibility
to that great power
That's right, exactly, the Marvel way. But the
one that I was really drawn to and wanted to
talk about is called Nextwave: Agents of H.A.T.E.
So I read this back when it came out. I think
it was a very, very short two volume series
basically. They put out two collections that
I own that are right here. Just to go show my-
There you go.
That one's backwards. There you go. there. So I
re-read them this morning or I re-read the first
one, I should say. It's a lot goofier than I
remember, but it was always... So basically
the premise here is that it's just kind of like
what if S.H.I.E.L.D. was extremely evil and dumb?
And instead of flying around in a flying aircraft
carrier, they flew around in a flying submarine.
And what if instead of having a super team
like the Avengers, they had a different
super team that went rogue because they
found out that they were evil and dumb?
So that's Nextwave. It's five superheroes, Photon,
Monica Rambeau, who we met in Captain Marvel,
the first Captain Marvel movie and then in
WandaVision, Machine Man who is a robot,
Elsa Bloodstone, who's the daughter of
an older Marvel character named Wolfgang
Bloodstone. I don't remember his first name,
something Bloodstone. And he fought monsters.
Wolfgang sounds good. I'll accept that.
It might be Wolfgang. I'm sure. Let's put it right
here what his actual name is. His name is this.
Bloodhound Gang.
Right. And then who else is in that? Boom-Boom
from X-Force whose power was to make things
explode. And there was one more. Oh, the captain,
this is the only brand new character. His name was
Captain, and then it had a bunch of asterisks
for a curse word. And so they just call him-
Oh, risque.
... The Captain. Yeah, so it was very edgy.
I'm imagining all the possibilities that
that could be and they're all funny.
So what's interesting about this book is that
it's basically just kind of this deconstruction
of superheroes generally. It's written by
Warren Ellis and illustrated by Stuart Immonen.
And so the art is really, really great.
It's really dynamic and exciting.
The writing is really stripped back. It's
very catchphrasey. It's very tongue-in-cheek.
It doesn't read as well today as I remember it.
When did it come out?
'07. So it's been a while. It's been a
minute. But I can see this coming to the
MCU in an interesting way because you've already
got Photon, and then the rest of the characters,
you could just introduce however the heck you
want. And you could just kind of make it more of a
Agents of S.H.E.I.L.D. with a higher budget,
not taking things too seriously, being
funny, sort of Guardians of The Galaxy
on earth. Let's just call it that, Guardians
of The Galaxy but on planet earth. And that's-
I can get behind that.
... basically what it is. Yeah.
The concept's a little too high,
like it can't be a one-to-one translation from the
comic book to the MCU. You'd have to do a lot of
adaptation. The tone of the book doesn't fit even
the rest of the Marvel universe. It takes place
in its own little thing. Just as an example, the
first issue starts in a town called Abscess, Iowa.
Nice.
It's intentionally goofy and silly and it's
not meant to be taken very seriously. So again,
it wouldn't fit super well in the MCU, but I
love the idea of a super-powered group of people
screwing up and taking down monsters. Like
in the first issue, they fight Fin Fang Foom,
who's this great character from the 60s who's
just a giant dragon in purple underpants.
Perfect.
So yeah. Nextwave: Agents of H.A.T.E.
instead of Agents of S.H.E.I.L.D.
I'm just imagining the poster is that Arrested
Development running gag of the Magicians Alliance
where it's like, they're all posing and it
says, "We demand to be taken seriously."
Exactly.
There's your movie poster just built in.
Yeah. I think there's room for it in the MCU. I
think that it would have to skew a little goofier
than a lot of the rest of it. But clearly Marvel's
ready to do things like that. Like the episode of
What If was extreme. I know it's animated already,
but this was the first episode of What If that
was basically a cartoon where Captain Marvel and
Thor fight because Thor is just throwing a party
that's going to destroy the earth. So they're
punching each other to different countries and
you can see the name of the country when you
zoom out to see the planet earth. It was very,
very goofy. So I'm thinking this is a long
walk to say, I think they could do it.
Sure. I don't see why not.
Thank you. Thank you for indulging me in
this long monologue early in the video.
You're welcome.
I hope people are still
watching. I somehow doubt it.
Oh, Brian.
But Nina.
Yes.
Nina, What super team do you think
you'd like to see in the MCU?
Bloodhound Gang, obviously.
I think they'd be a great fit. No, I have a
real pick. I promise. I was also looking at the
article on looper.com. This is going to be very
on brand for me, so everyone act really surprised
when I pick this. I picked the Lady Liberators.
Shocker. It was actually pretty interesting to do
some research on this because there've been two
team ups for the Lady Liberators and the first one
was in the 1970s, which is right when the second
iteration of the Equal Rights Amendment was being
championed by women's lib movements and stuff like
that. If you watched the FX show Mrs. America
from last year, you know all about that. And I
feel like four people have, and one of them is me.
But MCU star, Cate Blanchett was in it. So
anyway, basically in the first one, a woman that
appears to be Valkyrie and looks like Valkyrie,
she assembles a group that includes, let's see, it
has Wasp, Black Widow, Scarlet Witch, and Medusa
who we've not seen. Or am I correct that we've not
seen Medusa? Not in the big screen, certainly.
But has she been in any smaller spinoff thing?
Well, yeah, she was in the Inhumans show. That
did have a IMAX run. It was on the big screen-
Okay, that's-
If you were unlucky enough to pay-
... such a wild technicality.
... to pay money-
Worth every penny.
... to see it at IMAX.
Okay. Let me ask a differently
phrased question. Has Medusa been in
any phases, official ones of the
Marvel cinematic universe yet?
Technically Inhumans is part of the MCU,
but no one has ever mentioned it. So
I'm going to give it to you and say no.
Well, it has no bearing on whether or not the
Lady Liberators could be in it if she's been
in the MCU already or not. I just, I haven't
seen Inhuman, so I haven't experienced Medusa.
I also haven't-
So basically they team up. Yeah. And
so basically the woman who we later
learn is posing as Valkyrie, who is actually a
character we've discussed on the show before,
Amora the Enchantress from
Asgard, she tells this group of-
She of the fancy pants.
Yes, yes.
The fanciest pants in all the kingdom.
She tells them that she wants to battle
sexism in the world. So she gets the girls
together to go fight misogyny. And then at
the end of it, one male superhero is like,
"I hope you gals learned your lesson
about women's lib," or something awful.
And you're just like, oh, this was written
in 1970. No, they're just like, they're like,
"We'll come back again if we have to keep
defending feminism." But then they brought
it back in 2008 and it made slightly more sense.
And it was that She-Hulk got the crap kicked out
of her by Red Hulk and wanted revenge, and so she
assembles a team and this team is real Valkyrie,
Thundra joins, Black Widow, Susan Richards,
Tigra, Hellicat, Spider-Woman, and Storm.
So there's a lot of X-Men crossover.
Wait. You said Hellcat, right?
Yes.
I thought I heard you say Hellicat.
That's a better name.
That's a character.
She'd wave her tail around and fly.
I'm imagining Stan Lee pitching it right now.
Hellicat. It's a cat-
Okay, I have to write an email.
It's a cat but more helicopter.
I have to write an email to Marvel
after this about how Hellcat should
definitely become Hellicat and grow
little helicopters on her head.
I'm very sorry I interrupted you. Please go on.
No, that's totally fine.
The dumbest thing I could've said.
And apparently, no, it might be the dumbest
thing I've ever said because I said Hellicat.
But that's so much better than
Hellcat. Hellcat's fine but-
Is it?
Hellicat.
Just birthed a billion dollar franchise, Starner.
Welcome to the one Hellcat purist in the
comments who's going to be screaming for an hour.
Hellicat, the adventures I've already imagined-
is better than anything I've seen Hellcat-
Something I always have to thank
you two for is taking my dumb,
dumb mistakes and making them into
a solid riff. You do this so often.
All I know is dumb, dumb mistakes.
This is really, this is my wheelhouse.
Oh, man. So anyway, it's a huge group of
familiars. A lot of people like Susan Richards and
Storm would have to come in as part
of the assuming upcoming merge right?
Of everything coming back together. So obviously,
the modern iteration might be more difficult.
She-Hulk is coming soon. So it's again, not out
of the question. And I think the rumor about the
Olivia Wilde movie is that it is the Spider-Woman
movie, whatever she's doing at the MCU.
Oh, yeah that's right. Jessica Drew.
It's still not confirmed yet.
That's right.
But that is the rumor is that Olivia Wilde is
doing the Spider-Woman movie. And so basically,
this group subdues Red Hulk and they defeat him
and they avenge She-Hulk, and everybody has a
great time, et cetera, et cetera. But the reason,
the real reason I picked the Lady Liberators is,
look, I love Endgame. You guys
love Endgame. We all love Endgame.
But that scene of all the women
lining up was nice and pandering.
It was-
I'm really glad you said that.
It lasted for eight to ten
seconds and then it was over.
It was rough stuff.
I did not love it. And I know that that's
not a feeling that I feel by myself
in the world. I just would love to
see... especially because I feel like
there hasn't been a truly, truly awesome kind of
female led outing in the MCU just yet. I feel like
when you get people like Tatiana Maslany and
Tessa Thompson, and if Florence Pugh takes over
the Black Widow role, this could be a really
fun group of actresses to play around with.
I just think it could be a great time based
on who's already cast as these people.
Yeah. I think that there's going to be... I love
the expanded role that Wasp had in Antman and The
Wasp. I liked a lot of parts of Captain Marvel
and I'm really looking forward to the sequel.
I am too, yeah.
I think it's a pretty good movie-
I think it's going to be really fun.
... that could've been a lot better. But
yeah. I liked the character a lot and I
think that then we've got the Ms. Marvel show
that's coming, we've got the aforementioned
Kate Bishop Hawkeye, who is already a
lot more exciting than the other Hawkeye.
Yeah. And again, we have the aforementioned
She-Hulk with her own show. Yeah.
Exactly.
And so, we have a lot happening.
I liked parts of Captain Marvel
too. But the only thing about Captain
Marvel as a female superhero is she's
such a deus ex machina. She shows up and she
is always all powerful and that's it.
I think it's more interesting to... the Avengers
got the stuffing kicked out of them regularly, and
that's part of the tension. That's part of the fun
of a superhero movie. I think it could be great
to watch a group of female superheroes really
claw their way into a battle and reign supreme.
Yeah. I think it could be really cool.
Bring back Jessica Jones. Bring her back-
Oh my God. I loved her. Yeah.
So there's a lot of-
But have her play the character from
Don't Trust The B in Apartment 23.
Yeah, merge the two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Merge the two characters.
Rock solid.
I want her as that character, yeah.
Yeah, we should see if Disney
owns the rights to that show.
I believe that they do.
Good. Cool. Yeah. I think that's a great pick
and I think that if they could get some version
of that and make it not feel like a focus group
pandering eight second shot from a bigger movie-
Yeah. I would like the-
... that would be fantastic.
... opposite of the thing that happened
in End Game, but its own movie. Yeah.
Yeah.
I love it, I love it.
Me too. Thanks.
All right, now Tom, what is a Marvel team that
you'd like to see in the MCU? What can you
bring to the table here today? I don't think you
have much to bring to the table,
but maybe you'll prove me wrong.
Tom is always so unprepared for
these chats. It's so ridiculous.
I know. Yeah.
I'm a simple man with a simple mind.
I don't believe that for one second.
And I don't know art, but I know what I like.
And guys, what I want to talk about is X-Statix.
Brian, I think maybe you know a little bit
about it. Nina, I wasn't sure if you did or not.
Nope. I'm just going to
buckle up and enjoy the ride.
Well, let's go on a ride then. Okay.
I take you now to the year 1991.
Nina, you're a bouncing baby girl.
Yeah, I'm one.
Brian, you've just received your
first copy of AARP magazine.
Brian no longer has to pay to ride the public bus.
And his moons over my hammy cost
a mere 75 cents on the dollar.
They were good times.
And one of the biggest comic books in the world
is X-Force. It was created by Rob Liefeld. It is
the militaristic extension of the X-Men.
It's X-Men but with the pathos of-
X-Men plus guns.
Yeah. They're basically the X-Men but bad
guys, but still calling themselves good guys.
They get to kill a lot of people. You get lots of
classic characters. You get Cable, you get Domino,
you get the Shatterstar. Only of course, it's 1991
and it's Rob Liefeld so they're all extreme. It's
one of the most successful comics of the time
because it's exactly what everybody wants. It's
giant muscles and teeny tiny girl waists and
pouches on pouches. The series goes on and
it keeps being extreme, and time passes and
days turn into months, and months into years.
Ten years go by. The Hertz Rent A Car
company changes celebrity spokespeople.
With good reason.
In 2001, they're still doing their thing. There's
still an X-Force. It's a slightly different
group of people, but they're all still doing,
they're still very extreme. Only of course,
it's 2001. So now they're all wearing black
leather. 115 issues of this comic go on telling
the same continuous story. And then just
kind of out of nowhere, they all disappear.
With issue 116, they bring in a whole new
team with a completely different vibe. There's
kind of like a pop art look to it. It's written
by a new writer named Peter Milligan And it's
being drawn by Mike Allred who does this
terrific kind of semi Jack Kirby art style.
They bring in all of these new characters that
you've never heard of before. They're fantastic.
There's this guy named Zeitgeist
who at 13 years old, no 14 years old
finds out that his vomit can melt people's
flesh when he gets drunk at a party and
starts to make out with a girl and then
accidentally takes her face off. And then
there's this dude, Battering Ram who's your
classic muscle guy. He smashes through stuff.
He's very concerned about his place on the team.
You have got this Jinn Genie who can create
seismic waves as long as she's drunk. They're all
kind of trash cans is the cool thing. They are-
I just got my new Halloween costume.
See?
And it's Jinn Genie.
She speaks to a lot of us.
Perfect.
They're reality TV show stars is their thing.
They go out and they slaughter people wholesale on
pay-per-view television and they are famous
for being famous and for killing people.
It's this stunning indictment of the comic
book industry and what superheroes have become
and celebrity culture and everything.
There are all of these fantastic...
There's Plazm a kind of half
liquid, half gas, melty man. There's La Nuit
the Frenchman who controls dark energy.
There is of course everybody's favorite-
That's all Frenchman. Yeah.
Sluk. There's Sluk.
What's his name? Sluk?
Sluk.
He's got face things. That's his power. That's
how they describe it. He's got face things.
Oh my God.
So it's this fantastic new, weird, colorful
team that you would get a kick out of.
I-
They're a lot of fun.
I need this movie injected into my veins at the
next possible opportunity. I need it to
come out tomorrow. Is it already done?
It's good, right? I think
it could be a lot of fun.
I especially, I love Sluk. I don't
know if you love, I love Sluk.
I'm looking at Sluk, and how do you not
love? How do you not love a face like that?
That's what I'm saying. And that's
what makes it so difficult when
they kill him three pages into the first story,
Poor Sluk.
And then everybody else.
Oh, okay.
So everybody on the team is dead by the end
of the first issue, except for two characters
and the camera man for the group, a guy named
Dupe, who's just like a jelly bean that floats
around speaking alien speak all the time.
It is the grossest, weirdest comic book. I
loved this story so much. Every issue was like
this. They would bring in new characters and you
never knew who was going to make it to the next
story, who was going to be an ongoing character.
From a historical perspective, it's also
fascinating because it changed the way that Marvel
comics made stories at this point in history.
Up until now, ever since 1954, there was this
thing called the Comics Code Authority, which was
the comic book industry's way of self-regulating
and making sure that the government
didn't come in and put ratings on stuff.
They had to send all of their stories to
an objective third party, theoretically,
that was going to stamp them with approval
and say, "This isn't too violent and Batman
and Robin aren't going to do kissing.
So everything's going to be fine."
That's all true.
In 2001, they sent the first issue of this new
team, they sent this new team of X-Force members
to the Comic Code Authority and they
got back a message that said, "Yeah,
this isn't okay. It's horrifying." And Marvel
said for the first time in almost 50 years, "Eh,"
and they printed it anyway and they didn't care.
That was sort of the last nail in the coffin for
the Comics Code Authority. It would keep existing
a little bit for another 10 years, but by 2011,
the last game in town had stopped looking
for these people's approval. And people were
just kind of telling whatever
stories they wanted to tell.
So I think that's fascinating.
Because most of the people who write comic
books are people our age instead of
actual children, which is its own issue in
some ways. But here we are, here we are.
Here we are.
We've done something right, yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Anyway-
Chef's kiss. Perfect. No notes. Ten out of ten.
Terrific team. Yes. I would love-
I love it.
... to see this, especially if they did the
same thing. If they just didn't care about this-
Tom, who is your dream director?
... about what kind of rating it got.
For this movie?
Oh, man. Edgar Wright maybe.
Like who would...
Edgar Wright.
I was thinking Edgar Wright.
I was just about to say. Oh.
Yeah. Yeah, if he got-
But he-
He's done with Marvel.
If you get that Shaun of the Dead,
Hot Fuzz gore in there. Yeah.
Well, I could see it.
I could see it. Since a lot of the book is
predicated on that first issue going the
way it goes, you're introduced to all these
characters and then they all die by the end.
It seems more like it might make a really
good show versus a movie necessarily since
obviously Disney Plus is doing the MCU
shows now. I could see it happening. And
now with the merger, you're open all these
X characters that you weren't before. So-
If it's a show, I want to propose
the Always Sunny creative team. I
want to propose Glenn Howerton,
Rob McEleney and Charlie Day.
Oh, that could get so gross.
Charlie Day. Charlie Day is back-
They'd get so weird with it. Yeah.
Once Charlie Day is done voicing Luigi and voice-
Why did you remind me of
that? I was having a good day.
I hope he's never done voicing Luigi.
Not to get too far off topic, but a Chris Pratt,
Chris Pratt is Star-Lord so it's not too far off.
I think this movie might be a little
bit more interesting than people are
going to give it credit for,
because this cast is insane.
Legitimately insane.
Okay, sorry. I've derailed
us yet again. I apologize.
It happens.
Do you guys just want to do a quick
Mario episode while we're here?
Can I just say that the Super-
Dream Mario casting.
The Super Mario Brothers movie that we already
have is wonderful and I think not
enough people think it's great.
Because it is.
My man, we've already fought about this.
It's really good. It's a really good, good movie.
And I think people need to give it another chance.
Anyway. That's all I have to say. I feel like
we've done a poor job of finding an ending
for this episode, or at least I've done a poor
job as the ostensible person in charge. Sorry.
Do you want to just shout that?
Do we all get shot or our faces
melt off? It could work for-
What's that, Tom, what was the thing
faced character, Splurck? Splark?
Spluck?
Oh, Sluk.
I was close.
Sluk. I wasn't that far off. Yeah. So
just shout Sluk, and the episode's over.
That's it.
Is that how we should end the episode?
Probably.
Spluck!
Thanks for watching. Please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single video.